it's like yeah I took one look at you
it's like how much longer do you want to
live as a New York five because you
could be in Idaho nine with one plane
ticket baby and so I I feel like every
city should have to make their pitch as
to why a 20-something year old should
move there and live there that a 25 year
old I might create a whole new show
around just this just this pitch
[Music]
Ben this is your segment you you own
this segment you take it away all right
here we go we're reviewing the news
we're letting the boys react uh
by the way I like the thing you started
doing where you're like fellas
I think that's kind of like on the first
episode of the news of the boys react I
feel like you kind of nailed the catchy
thing like that was pretty natural by
you good good move by you fellas there
is a new Instagram the founders
Instagram are back with a new app it's
called artifact it's being described as
Tick Tock for text
um fellas is this the next big thing
damn did you see this thing so the page
says I'm trying to pull it up the page
doesn't really say what it is it's okay
they they in the news they kind of
talked a little bit more so I heard Tick
Tock for text and I was like okay what
is that basically it means two things
number one Kevin system the founder of
Instagram was like when I saw Tick Tock
and how the feed works where you just
open the app you're already in you don't
have to follow a bunch of people you
just start swiping and it just learns
what you like he's like oh this is the
way everything should work this way I
can't believe Twitter doesn't work this
way I can't believe why are we still
trying to do this like manual follow
interesting people thing when I suggest
the the app should just give you what
you're interested in uh through machine
learning so he goes that's number one
number two what they're doing is they're
instead of what Tick Tock did for videos
these guys are trying to do with news
actually not just text but news so
they're trying to serve you text-based
news based on your interest
um and that's where
that's where he lost me I don't think
people want to read a bunch of news in
the same way that they're willing to
like swipe through mindless videos for
entertainment and so I think that's
where
it has this problem that a lot of
Silicon Valley ideas have which is they
try to sell you what you should do
instead of what you want to do and it
sounds Noble and high and mighty and
when they go to dinner parties and they
say this is what we're gonna do
everybody you know Pats them on the back
but I think that this is not going to
work for news so I'm out
so here's the thing that I'm wondering
by the way you like how I went Shark
Tank on it and now I'm in or out that's
maybe a new that might be a new part of
this I'm not I'm out all right well you
can't see me but I'm holding like I've
been watching Andrew Tate videos because
it's just hilarious now that he's in
jail and it's kind of funny he always
holds his hands like in a V when he's
sitting down uh and that's like how the
alpha sits so you gotta like if you're
gonna say you're out you gotta like sit
with like your yeah yeah yeah there you
go you gotta like so that's yeah there
it is that's all Alpha sit according to
Andrew Tate let me try that again and
for that reason
I'm out yeah a little I had a little
snap to it my wrist felt a little
something there yeah so here's the thing
um they've been this guy Kevin Systrom
killed it right you know this little
fella he created Instagram awesome been
out of the game that's Ring rust my
friend when you I watch it absolutely
I've watched enough uh fighting to know
that ring rust is real for a lot of
people so I wonder like is he actually
in touch with uh what people want is he
hungry is him and his partner you know
they're billionaires flying on planes
with Ashton Kutcher does he actually
know what people want
but I don't know about you but I study a
lot of Japanese like he's like Ashton
Ashton I see you got Tick Tock open
wouldn't you rather that those were all
just news articles
dude I the the I love studying like how
the Chinese and particularly the
Japanese do things the Japanese these
news apps in Japan are so popular it
works wonderfully now what works in
Japan it don't necessarily work here two
totally different cultures there's a
term for that I'm not going to pretend
to even know what that term is but it's
like basically when things work in Japan
and vice versa in America it doesn't
always translate to each of those
cultures because they're so different
but it works there maybe it could work
here in fact I think the parent company
of bite dance uh or Tick Tock bite dance
they have another app which is basically
this it's an algorithmic news app called
I don't know how you pronounce like
teautau I don't know I don't know how
you say it's Xiao I don't know what the
name of it is but this is what it does
and it's super super popular so maybe
maybe yeah that's the right answer baby
but uh I don't know
it's just I think it's hard to be a
billionaire
who's been out of the game and to start
something from scratch I think that
uh I gotta I gotta give us a director's
note here so
I was watching something uh somewhere
and basically uh I was watching first
take the you know like the I don't know
if you've ever watch these ESPN shows
where it's like two guys doing this they
react to the news
um
these shows only work if you disagree so
um basically on all of these by default
you got to take one side and then I
gotta argue the other uh regardless of
how I actually feel so if I'm out you
gotta be in and I think it's a good case
to be in to say you know this actually
already Works in China and Japan so just
I'm just saying good content comes from
disagreement not agreement I was a hard
maybe you were a hard no that's kind of
a disagreement yeah that's far enough
it's far enough all right all right what
else we got Ben all right next one
uh the thing everyone is talking about
tech layoffs more than 150 000 Tech
workers have already been laid off in
the last six months that includes 12 000
at Google 18 000 Amazon 11 000 meta 10
000 Microsoft so fellas any advice for
our fallen comrades comrades I hate that
these people use the word comrades I saw
dude we are not comrades these guys made
like they're trying to do the Soviet
Union [__] bro you made 600 000 a
year in Cash Plus another 250 000 in
stock bonuses and you had free pizza
every single day yeah we are now you can
drink oat milk like get out of here yeah
yeah yeah we are not comrades like you
know like like you know comrades don't
like eat grape upon we are not that so I
hate when people say comrades and plus
we're not even Conrad conrades I don't
know a person who works at Google
whenever Sam lacked motivation he would
just go meet a lazy Google engineer and
just be and just get their W-2 salary
out of them and then he was like fuel
ignited back to the lab I am dude I
remember I went to the Facebook campus
once and I remember I overheard people
complain that the line for the so like
Facebook's campus for those who haven't
gone it's basically like a like it's
like a mall it's like a mall but
everything's free I'm not joking I wrote
an article about this actually if you
look up like Sam par Facebook office
they had a vending machine but instead
of candy bars it was like computers yeah
iPhone Char you could get like a
computer MacBook charger if you just
like push if you push D3 you would just
get a huge MacBook charger yeah it was
all free it's incredible and then they
had like a dentist they had a barber
they had a dude I swear to God they had
a wood making like a wood shop like you
can go and like there's a van you could
just go and get a hand job if you're
bothering you it's crazy dude they have
everything there they you could go and
leave your car and your oil would get
changed when you came back from work I
remember seeing all this stuff and I
just thought of like oh this is it we
made it and then I realized that the
tenure at Facebook is like 18 months and
so I was like oh okay this isn't
actually all the good so anyway long
story short these people ain't comrades
okay but what are they gonna do I
actually don't know like is a hundred
thousand is 150 000 layoffs I'm not I'm
not well versed enough in like the macro
economy what's going to happen to them I
I don't know do I think they're gonna
start companies no I don't some will
some will and I think that's uh that's
good
um I think it's good to recite I think
it's good for these companies to trim
the fat they got way too much fat uh
when I went and when we were getting
acquired by twitch twitch had I think 2
000 employees at the time and um they
made me like do go through a round of
interviews during the acquisition
process like you know meet the team and
whatever and they would ask me questions
for 55 minutes and then the last five
minutes they would say do you have any
questions for us and I just said how
many employees does twitch have and then
they would say 2000 and then I'd say how
many employees do you think twist should
have
and uh this was my IQ test for them and
I was trying to see uh if I was actually
not even IQ test it was an honesty test
um who here has the courage to say a
number less than two thousand and um
only one most were just taken aback by
the question because they knew what I
was implying uh because they you know if
they said if they said more I just
started laughing uncontrollably if they
said 2000 is the right number I would
raise the people's eyebrow and be like
oh really you just happen to have the
perfect match of resources to to needs
like isn't that isn't that fortunate
that you guys are just playing it
perfectly wow you guys are amazing
leaders and if they were honest and said
you know
um
if we wanted to just keep doing what
we're doing we probably only need 250
amazing people and for us to do some of
the new initiatives new bets I think
maybe another another hundred people
would be would be right
I would stand and give them I would give
them a standing ovation in a job
interview which is awkward because
they're just sitting down in front of me
uh only one person was honest in that
out of the seven that I talked to that
day the rest were liars and so uh so
yeah these companies have had it coming
they need to trim the fat if you got
laid off it's okay I'm sure you will
bounce back you uh you've had a very
very cushy situation for a very long
time hopefully you built up a little
safety net for yourself and uh go do
something interesting I think this is a
healthy recycling and flushing of the
system
um you know this is the juice cleanse
for Silicon Valley right this is the
detox cleanse for silica Valley it needs
to it needs needed to happen dude juice
cleanses are the stupidest thing it's
not like it's not like the juice is like
a pipe cleaner my influencers tell me
differently dude I hate when people talk
about this like it's not like you're
just like you have like gunk in your
veins and like the juice goes through
like a pipe cleaner just pulling the
gunk cleaning your veins I always hated
that idea of a cleanse but in this case
yeah I think that is actually true [__]
we're agreeing again but um dude a lot
of a lot of these companies are really
generous uh like they're giving six
months uh lee or six months Severance
and if you have been there for a while
you get even more so I actually think
that it you know now's a good
opportunity to turn [__] into gold and
take you know two months to freaking
chill which sorry they kind of already
were I bet but take some time to like
actually chill and then get after it and
um you know there's I've been thinking
about uh job hunting I call it job
hunting because a lot of people think of
like oh I'm out I hope hopefully I'll
find a job and I'm like no no Now's the
Time to job hunt you know you make like
a list of 10 companies where you're
going to work you uh find the hiring
manager and you hunt them down and you
get that job you know it's a hunt it's
not like a you know I'll just apply to
these 100 companies on indeed and hold
slash their tires you put your resume
inside the tire when they go to find it
that's all they know you wanted it yeah
so now's that time and I I always
perform best when I have my backings to
all you know we use that phrase burn the
burn the ships or burn the boats you
know you now is maybe a good time so
hopefully people will find opportunity
in it but let's get one straight one
thing straight
we're not comrades okay give me a break
I I hate that stuff I didn't cut the
words comrade listen comrades and
solidarity I never want to hear that
word solidarity again
more behind the scenes someone else
wrote the question which they actually
wrote uh any advice for our fallen
brothers and sisters but I like to thank
you as Sam who is just setting himself
up for like I'm gonna I'm gonna set up
this question and tear it down don't say
solidarity don't say comrade if you make
over a hundred thousand dollars a year
you you don't you don't get solidarity
okay uh these next ones rapid fire okay
uh Doomsday Clock the Doomsday Clock got
moved to 90 Seconds To Midnight uh this
is largely due to fears that the Ukraine
war could escalate into a nuclear
conflict Doomsday Clock is all these
nuclear scientists who just tell us how
close the world is to ending fellas are
we all gonna die no
I I've I honestly had never even heard
of this Doomsday Clock Ben you're the
historian around here is this a common
is this something I should have known
about and uh does this happen all the
time or how big of a deal is this bed
and it's not like by the way it's not
like a clock right it's more like a
meter is this like Smokey the Bear like
uh like what's the threat of like a
bonfire so it is a wildfire
you know like there's smoke in the bear
it's like today's like a day where like
there could be a fire the clock is a bad
thing because yeah yeah it's always hits
midnight it started during uh during the
Cold War and there's basically a bunch
of nuclear scientists got together and
wanted to tell everyone how close the
world was to ending so everyone would
take the threat of nuclear war nuclear
disarmament very seriously the problem
with the with the clock is it started at
I think like three minutes to midnight
and so like every time something happens
they're like oh we're we're actually
really close we're Two Minutes to
Midnight
um and and the clock moves back and
forth a little bit so uh so we're at
like the 50 yard line basically that's
also a dumb analogy why that's a
distance
because what they were trying to do is
like give people this feeling of
impending doom right like it's only a
matter of time Russia and the United
States for you or like uh
you know what do you need like a
weightlifting analogy I want like a like
a like a like a temperature bulb you
know like the temperature can go up and
down I just think look you want the
Smokey the Bear thing
I was thinking about this
since like humans started existing if
this was like a book it would be like a
thousand pages and the period that we're
in now would be like a paragraph on the
thousandth page and I just I just think
I am not so important that this one
paragraph is going to be more important
than the rest of the Thousand pages so I
almost always refuse to believe that
anything doomsday related is gonna
happen while I'm here so no I'm not
worried about this at all
that was a good analogy by the way the
book thing you're welcome that's a free
one all right uh chat GPT can pass a
bunch of tests now uh it can pass the
U.S medical licensing exam and it passed
a test from the Wharton MBA program
University of Pennsylvania uh are you
annoyed that you didn't have the chance
to use chat GPT to cheat in high school
and or college hey hey Ben how come you
didn't read the uh the actual headline
that's written in the doc I'm curious
well what's wrong with that one
it says chat GPT is rgbt is Asian how
good it is at taking these tests and I
gotta say
I had my human chat gbt I was a prolific
cheater throughout School uh fifth grade
reading program I ordered I organized a
Syndicate I realized that if I I was not
going to read 32 books and win but I had
10 friends and if we each read three
books that we could get to the 30
bookmark and all win we would all just
take the test for each other that's what
we did I won the teacher called my mom
let her know that I had cheated my mom
couldn't have been prouder uh the second
thing that happened
um you know math tests they used to uh
give us a TI-83 calculator and
um my buddy used to be smarter than me
and take the test before me and then he
would just type in all of the answers
into the TI-83 calculator under the Y
equals sign button and I used to just
simply open that up and fill in the
answers and go on my way so I don't need
Chad gpt3 I was ahead of the curve on
this and um I you know cheater's gonna
cheat dude we used to take you know how
you're allowed to have like a water
bottle at in school we used to take the
labels off like the Dasani bottles and
write the answers and the cheat sheet on
the back of the label and then put the
label back on and that was where the
answers were and so
I don't know man that deserves an a just
for that but uh am I jealous that they
have this
yeah sure but I'm not jealous that I'm
in school again nerds so
we win that one
I have a wife yeah yeah
by the way Sean I didn't read the
headline because it only got a B on the
test at Wharton so I'm not sure if
God nice nice I have nothing to do with
this what else you got all right uh
Justin Bieber uh sold his share of his
back catalog for 200 million dollars to
an investor smart move yeah
definitely why why did he do it you know
has he had income coming in like why I
think somebody said his tour got
canceled but that I mean is he really
living tour to tour at this point I I
don't know
I think I would just assume it was a
good offer and he had to make a decision
he decided yeah so let's go with that
dude Dr Dre did the same thing and
people are like why would you do that
and someone said well listen to this so
he got he recently got divorced and so
he owes his wife you know half of what
he had he probably made 500 million
dollars off of Beats half of that went
to his wife and then there was another
article that said in the divorce it was
released that they were spending three
million dollars a month so on travel
clothes so that's 36 million dollars
Neil potato status yeah man holy moly so
he actually probably needed the money is
it smart yeah he he better go write some
hits now man he better get dancing uh
but yeah you know look dude he sold it
the work that he did from 13 to like 30
he sold for 200 million dollars that's
pretty dope and by the way he sold just
his share the the like he owns only a
smallest part you know his agent and
then the label owns it and the whoever
there's like four other parties involved
in this so he just sold his share which
means his total back catalog has got to
be worth close to a billion dollars
um
a good move in fact I'm just going to
say this now
if I ever sell something for 200 million
dollars and people come to be
questioning if this was a good move
you're getting a slap you're getting a
slap from me and like do you need an
explanation as to why I took this 200
million dollar check like I mean how
dare you you better have 900 million
dollars if you're gonna ask me a
question like that if you ask me that
question I will say please show me 900
million dollars before I answer this
question otherwise you get in a slap and
uh so so yeah I do not question this
also Bieber makes good decisions he
follows me on Twitter
two dots make a line baby that's two
data points of Bieber making good
decisions and that's a lot two dots
don't make a line but uh
just because it Rhymes and sounds good
it doesn't mean that it actually works
any two points can be connected by a
line two dots make a line all right does
he really does he really follow you on
Twitter by the way he does dude DM him
did you DM him
uh I never have been sort of crafting
the right way
a couple dozen years now how many people
did they follow how many other people
does he follow smooth two hundred eighty
thousand oh
there's the line does he follow you
does he follow any of the bends on this
call no dude by the way uh you made the
announcement on one pod that you want a
woman to reach out to you because you
have a great d2c idea that you want to
help from a woman
I have had like 15 women reach out to me
half of them think that I'm you because
we only have four female listeners so
they must have told them oh by the way
we're not saying that anymore someone
had to talk with me I'm gonna bring it
up next part we're gonna we shouldn't
say that anymore I'm gonna explain why
but for now that joke is killer okay no
it's not and I'll explain why later but
listen I've had about 15 women and like
seven of them like have a million
followers on Instagram and like wow
their profiles are are such that when
I'm scrolling through them and Sarah my
wife is sitting next to me she's like
what are you looking at because it's
like the hottest Instagram models in
like bikini models and things like that
so like I don't know what you're getting
at but
it probably worked I don't know what
you're working yeah so I had so many
people reach out to me well well send
them to me right why do they reach out
to you oh it's because my Instagram's
like private and like locked uh oh yeah
that's not gonna be that's not gonna
work yes still I'm still uh I've there's
definitely been some good Outreach I'm
talking to two people who I think are
the right how many people
uh I don't know I didn't count maybe 20
25 something like that I had a lot of
serious people reached out I had a lot
and there and and and up yeah they're
trying to reach you or they think that
I'm you it's pretty funny
um but anyway that's that
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
I have just one last one last one which
is a new study uh shows how much money
you need to make to be in the top one
percent income earner in every state 850
000 in California New York Connecticut
is tops actually surprisingly with nine
hundred thirty thousand dollars the
bottom is West Virginia uh with three
hundred seventy thousand dollars per
year to be the top one percent this
question is specifically for Sam Sam
what do you have to say to my comrades
who are not in the top one percent oh
oh
um I actually am going to do a big thing
about this next episode that shows that
you can be in the one percent of New
York and make that income and still not
be able to retire because that's how
much it costs to live there
um yeah dude move to Missouri uh I think
that's crazy 800 000 is so much money
um it's so much money so eight hundred
thousand dollars by the way is 456 000
post-tax and
um if you assume that you spend fifteen
or twenty thousand dollars a month which
is very reasonable
and that means they're saving like 200
Grand a year you just gotta you gotta
make that for 20 years in order to
actually be able to retire which is even
crazier than the 800 000 stat if you're
making that much money in New York
I'm getting a remote job ASAP and moving
to you know uh West Virginia or Florida
I'd rather if I'm just making a W-2
income I'd rather live like a king in
Florida than live like a plebe in New
York and be in the rat race so get out
that's what I that's what I would do
yeah people always talk about
um you know the big city and all that
stuff but big fish small pond uh you
know that is a a a uh what do we call a
small pond syndrome you want to have
small pond syndrome that that is a much
more better way to live now of course
there's no there's no end to that you
could go live you could be at the top
one percent in uh Thailand with probably
like I don't know 120 Grand so so you
know there's no there's no end to that
but it definitely just shows how much of
a ripoff California and New York are and
uh I think I say this you live in New
York half the year and I live in
California the full year so you know who
are we to say but like Charlottesville
pretty nice Boise Charlottesville not
bad no this time of year yeah lovely
this time of year the Land of Lincoln
it's beautiful uh honestly like places
like California you're like oh wow
that's a lot but then you scroll down
you're like South Carolina 500 000 man
like Idaho 508 000 really like you gotta
like why why would that be why would
that be so high and um they're not
they're not bringing enough assets to
the table or as you like to say you got
to have some attributes at least
California's got the oceans it's got the
weather it's got this you know the
scenery it's got the celebrities it's
got whatever you want Silicon Valley
Hollywood you gotta have some attributes
if you're gonna be gonna be demanding
this level of income up to be in the top
one have you ever been to Flora Bama in
Georgia you know what that is Flora Bama
I'm sorry Flora Bama in in Alabama you
know you know so we're Alabama and in
the Florida Line meets this is where we
would go for our Island grew up in
Missouri all Missouri people go to
Florida for spring break you go to
Flora-Bama it's the Line This is the MTV
show right yeah it's the it's the
redneck Riviera my friend it is the
trashiest place on Earth and it is so
fun you could eat popcorn shrimp all day
for four dollars Flora Bama is the place
to go you get those Alabama prices while
being on the basically the Florida coast
it's all right I actually think there
should be a Pitch competition like Shark
Tank that's just cities or states just
doing what you just did be like you ever
wanted to wake up and have shrimp
because we we do that here right like
you're tired of not having shrimp before
10 a.m because that's not a problem in
the in the the redneck Riviera
fried popcorn shrimp grouper for dinner
it's the best man Florida's the place to
be you don't have to own socks it's the
best man no shirt no shoes no problem
I'm all about the floor Bama it's like
yeah I took one look at you it's like
how much longer do you want to live as a
New York five because you could be in
Idaho nine it was one plane ticket baby
and so I I feel like every city should
have to make their pitch as to why a
20-something year old should move there
and live there that a 25 year old I
might create a whole new show around
just this just this pitch yeah man we
need some uh we need uh Alaska to
sponsor this pod
um all right I think that's it right
that's it
[Music]
foreign